mike Mayock back here in the Rich Eisen
show right Mike your your mock free guy
until the day before twist your arm and
get one out of here they squeeze one out
of here the night before the draft yeah
the irony is rich is that for years the
anaphor network will get mad at me
because I only wanted to do one a year
and they try to get me to do more and
I'd be like now you only need one and
when all the informations in we'll do it
and they kind of several years ago said
well if you're only one let's put it on
television so it's it's it's come full
circle they kept pushing me to do more
more on the.com site and when I didn't
all of a sudden it became a TV show and
it's got a little bigger than life look
Mike you never knew you're just a
Content generator man you're a Content
generating machine but that's just uh
that's just who you are
at your bones I don't yeah whatever you
want to start with a quarterback's Mike
what do you think what do you think rich
you started anywhere else I might have
had a heart attack
why'd Sam why Sam Donald why is he
number one for you on your first
position rankings that's a quarterback
there are five or six quarterbacks this
year rich that conceivably could have a
first-round grade which is more than
usual it's a deeper class than we've had
the guys up top I think there's a hole
in almost everybody's game and we could
dig as deep as one of them but at the
end of the day I don't know any of these
dudes I've never met Sam Donald so I'm
only going off tape which was difficult
because for instance when in the Carson
Wentz thing I jumped in with both feet
because not only did I love his tape but
I like to kid even more and what he
brought to the table leadership
intelligence etc so last year at this
time I think I had DeSean Kaiser as my
number one quarterback on the first top
five and the more I dug into that the
less I like that so with that all being
a caveat the reason I'm with Donald
right now is I think he's
a prototypical NFL drop that guy 64 plus
or minus 220 he's got plus arm strength
he's a plus athlete he's competitive I
like the fact that he played three
sports in high school including point
guard in his basketball season you can
see that he's got a competitive fires
pushes the ball down the field you know
I like almost everything about him and
the big caveat 4,000,000 it is a big one
our eternal especially fumbles they've
got the guys fumbled a lot going back to
high school football so you got to kind
of take a look at that and say is that
fixable and I think a lot of what he
does in the pocket is fixable because
he's gotten into a bad habit of only
keeping his right hand on the ball
instead of his offhand for protection
and Josh Allen what do you see about him
that you like you put him two over Josh
Rosen what do you think yeah he's the
exact same height and weight as Carson
Wentz and he's coached by the same
height coach that had Carson Wentz oh
he's coming out of a pro-style attack I
I don't know where he is on the
intangible side compared to Carson Wentz
but he's just as athletic he's got a
bigger arm he's got the biggest arm in
this draft or any of the last five or
ten drafts that doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to be a great quarterback
all you have to do is look at your
markers Russell who had eight shoes on
so you're taking a little bit of a leap
of faith on a kid that's got all the
tangibles in the world big strong rocket
arm supposed to be a smart kid supposed
to be a hard worker the thing I'm
struggling to get over is his 56%
accuracy in college football and very
rarely does a guy become a 64 percent
guy that was 56 in college so that's
what's got me was I'm trying to climb or
tape and determine with some other
quarterback coaches around the league
you know is it is it quote fixable
deepest is this the deepest quarterback
draft you've seen in a while or compared
it yeah yeah I mean you between Donald
Alan Rosen Maceo Lamar Jackson Mason
Rudolph there's six names that
conceivably be first-round
and then right on top of that I mean
Luke Falk from Washington State
Kyle wall Letta from richmond mike white
played his bottle off at the Senior Bowl
there's even more that's nine and in a
typical quarterback year rich there's
been an average of 12 taken over the so
there's nine of the twelve draftable
ones right off the top of our heads and
and I think it's a really there's some
quality at the top and there's depth
throughout and so being the Belichick
whisper that you are for me which one do
you think he might look at first blush
right now because clearly with Jimmy G
now in San Francisco and everything
that's playing out New England a lot of
people think they're definitely gonna
draft one what do you think Mike which
one do you think suits him I have no
idea I mean again it's February I
haven't met any of them I don't know I
don't know what they're so football IQ
is I don't know if they think that their
quarterback can play another two years
or another five years so you know
they've been in the quarterback business
for a while now I mean it's been per set
it was Jimmy G before that it was Ryan
Mallett they've been in the second or
third round quarterback business for a
while because of the uncertainty of Tom
Brady and they will continue to be in
that purgatory mike Mayock here in the
Rich Eisen show so then what's the deep
is quarterback the deepest of all of the
offensive positions or is there is there
something that we're not touching on
offensively right now well I think
though I think the running back class
last year was as good as I've ever seen
it I think that's going to be close
you know that's a qualm Barkley arguably
is the best player in the draft I think
it's a top five pick various guys Ronald
Jones so much Michele Nick job Rashad
Penny carry on Johnson and you can go on
for another 15 names on top of that I
think we're going to see just like last
year you know where you get a Kareem
hunt where was he in the third round I
believe
Alvin Kamara in the third round right I
think I gave him the Green Bay in like
in my mock draft could you imagine could
you imagine Mike
Wow I just don't I don't understand what
people didn't see him I thought just and
maybe it was because he transferred from
Alabama to Tennessee and then didn't
play for sure and you know there was
some murkiness surrounding him but the
taught that talent was undeniable and
then defensively
what's the deepest position on the
defensive side of the ball you think
probable I mean the interior defensive
lineman led by this freak from
Washington named vitae verify I mean
he's a 340 pound dancing bear that
people say might run 485 at the combine
which I don't know if he will or not but
between him and Garron painting and more
resourced the Bryant kid from Florida
Harrison Phillips from Stanford there's
five names that are gonna be defensive
tackles and you NFL and they're all
potential first-round picks so I think
the defensive tackles are deep and I
think I got to get deeper in the corners
but but I'm kind of liking some of the
corners that I've been getting into to I
think that's gonna be a pretty good well
Bradley Chubb is being thrown about I
know again in the mock draft world that
you don't dive into until the very end
the chub is being mentioned as a top
three pick the Colts would take him
maybe the you know the Giants even
although I would be stunned if they
don't take a quarterback or or Barkley
in that position how good is this kid
Chubb from NC State absolutely legit and
another top 5% six pick clean off the
field we've got a bunch of kids this
year whether it's Barkley the guard from
Notre Dame Quentin Nelson Bradley job
there and I could say five more that are
just outstanding players plus really
clean off the field so I think if you
have a top ten pick this year and forget
about quarterbacks because you and I
know that that can go anyway I mean last
year the quarterbacks and the wide
receivers went off the board way for
earlier than I thought they would so
there's some really top and quality
talent they're also clean off the field
this year now
you be breaking it down fought the top
five at each position that's again on
nfl.com all over NFL Network at mike
Mayock on Twitter and all that said do
you have a draft board right now one
through whatever is there a single
person that's sitting there at the top
of your draft board right now no hmm I
don't that a little bit later but okay I
will tell you right now you're asking me
who the best player in the draft that
buys my waiver yes who do you have yeah
we would probably would either be tape
on Berkeley or Clinton Nelson a guard
really why because he's he's again your
ask me the best player and yes sir and
right he's 300 members act Martin Joe of
course came at a Notre Dame and became
an all-pro first year
this kid is 330 pounds where Zach was
about 310 his feet aren't quite as good
but they're close and he plays with a
nasty demeanor he hasn't been hurt I
think he's a day one all-pro guard and
it doesn't mean he's gonna go in the top
ten and the last two I think rich the
last two top ten guards we're the same
year was chance for Mack and the kid
Cooper from North Carolina Jonathan
Cooper and neither of them has had a
type of career people thought they would
so there's a little bit of reticence
about a guard in general and especially
with recent history but I believe this
gets flat-out
unbelievable football player all right
before I let you go Mike the low-hanging
fruit portion of our conversation that
you always love in all services the the
scouting community hearing that Johnny
Manziel has in his mind turned the
corner he's going to the the spring
league to try and get back into the
league well how's this got in community
looking at that yeah pretty much wait
and see you know we have to as a
community Scout him and be aware of him
he has talent has he cleaned himself up
it it's a nice opportunity to get a
snapshot of where this kid is both on
and off the field and I think more than
anything
curry ASSA T and some teams that have to
follow through on it
there are you you think there will be
some teams that are gonna do some
serious due diligence and see if he's
for real
again I think that's why I have scouting
departments I think it's incumbent upon
you you do diligence on any legitimate
NFL potential player and he is one of
those okay and our poll question today
Mike is which quarterback is the best
quarterback in baseball spring training
Russell Wilson or Tim Tebow Mike Matt
[Laughter]
that's not our poll question today
specifically for Mike it is okay I think
I think I'm a better hitter than either
of them that's right you were drafted
right were you Mike centerfielder you
never worked I turned I turned it down I
got called by most of the teams in the
league my senior year in high school
right then the night before the draft
and basically saying hey there exactly
tomorrow you know what happens you know
I said I'm gonna go to play football
Boston College mm my dad who was my high
school football coach just sat there and
shook his head like you are the dumbest
human being I've ever met
thought I was a better baseball here we
are man and and then the last question I
would be remiss if I did not give you
the floor you being a Philly guy having
seen what the Eagles did for that town
we were there for the draft and what the
draft put on display for the fandom of
foot football in Philadelphia just paled
in comparison to what we saw on the
Superbowl running that and that parade
you had the floor serum what what do you
think the Eagles victory meant for that
city I think Jason Kelsey summed it all
up I was one of the best beaches I've
ever seen heard his frustration is
mentality that about what everybody else
said about his Eagles and I think that
in capital encapsulates this entire city
that hasn't had a football championship
since 1960 it's a tough passionate city
that loves their Philadelphia Eagles at
the end of the day I think the spirit
and and that parade was outstanding and
I'd be remiss if I didn't say that I
think what Howie Roseman has done in the
last years is mind-boggling
and in conjunction duck Pearson who most
of Philadelphia didn't want hired two
years ago shows you what happens when
two intelligent people are joined
hip-to-hip philosophically in every
other way and I'll tell you what the
development of this team from a
personnel perspective and a coaching
perspective was amazing all right Mike
thanks the two cents is there any amount
of money speaking of two cents in the
world where I can get you to put on
Kelsey's outfit from the parade two-time
meme the 40-yard dash in a couple of
weeks yes come on Mike and you know do
you know what his outfit was was it
something specific it's some sort of
Genie or P but that's what the net
that's what the national perspective of
anybody from Philly knew what it was
right away what is it he was paying
respect to the mummer's parade okay
there you go they're walking through
Philly and New Year's buggin that's a
big deal in Philadelphia that's what he
was he was kind of like a mini moment he
was walking around the streets drinking
a beer hanging out with the cops and the
people okay so that's a yes then and it
was unbelievable so that's a yes no not
from no we're not mummering in turn that
into a verb thanks Mike look forward to
a pleasure oh you got smoke man the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience